- I love the climb.
I truly believe the
definition of an entrepreneur
is loving the process more
than the things
you get out of it.
I don't like the stuff.
I don't want watches.
Fuck cars.
I don't need planes.
I don't need dick.
I need the process,
I need to buy the Jets, period.
I truly believe that
I will never really fully
capitalize on all the money
or all the opportunities
because I think I always leave
a little bit on the table
because I want to keep playing.
I want to keep playing.
And I think that that's the
part that I'm curious about in
the audience which is
what's the divide for you
between how much do you want
to keep playing and
how much do you want the
fruits that come along with
success in winning the game?
I find it stunningly
interesting that
of course I like having money
but I am equally as happy
right now as I was paying myself
$27,000 a year at 23 years old
because the building of the game
and I really do believe that
separates me and
the people in this
audience that have that
from the people that don't.
That they think it's a
means to an end.
That they'll make more
money doing it themselves
versus working for somebody.
And to me that's the pure
definition of entrepreneurship.
(light beat)